STATE DEPARTMENT, THANK YOU.
LET'S GET SOME ADDITIONAL
INSIGHT INTO THE SITUATION.
MIKE POMPEO JOINS ME LAUGH
TONIGHT FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
>> IT'S GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
>> Bret: YOU ARE THE SET UP,
WE KNOW WHAT YOU SAID TODAY
ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT THIS MOMENT
IS THAT NO ONE SHOULD BE
SURPRISED BY IT.
HOWEVER THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
INSIDE THE PENTAGON WE ARE TOLD,
SENIOR MILITARY OFFICIALS WHO
ARE SURPRISED BY THE
ARE SURPRISED BY IHE
ARE SURPRISED BY IT.
THEY FEAR COULD MEAN HARM BY
U.S. TROOPS BY A ROCK.
YOUR TO THAT?
>> WE JUST CALL THE REALITY OF
WHAT IT IS, THEY ARE A TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION WE HAVE NOT
DESIGNATED THEM.
WE ARE ALWAYS DOING EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO PROTECT EVERY AMERICAN
SOLDIER.
EFFECT OF THE IRG C, THEY HAVE
KILLED OVER HUNDRED AMERICAN
SOLDIERS, SO YOU CAN HAVE PEACE
AND YOU CAN'T HAVE STABILITY AND
SECURITY IN THE MIDDLE EAST
WITHOUT WEAKENING THE ISLAMIC
REVOLUTIONARY GUARD CORPS AND
THAT IS WHAT OUR SANCTIONS ARE
AIMED AT DOING.
WE ARE CONFIDENT, THIS INCREASED
PRESSURE WILL SAVE AMERICAN
LIVES AND CREATE MORE STABILITY,
MORE PEACE AND SECURITY
THROUGHOUT THE MIDDLE EAST.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW THE IRAQI
FORCES, THE MILITIAS ARE TIGHT
WITH THE IRAQI ARMY.
U.S. TROOPS OBVIOUSLY WORK WITH
BOTH OF THEM FRANKLY.
HOW WILL THEY DISTINGUISH AND
WILL THIS BECOME A COMPLICATED
PROBLEM?
>> IT WAS A COMPLICATED PROBLEM
ONE OBAMA ENTERED THAT DISASTER
IS DEAL.
WE HAD A LONG CONVERSATION WHEN
I WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE CIA,
IT WAS COMPLICATED LONG BEFORE
THIS MORNING.
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS
REDUCE THE COMPLEXITY AND
TAKEDOWN THIS MALIGN ACTIVITY
THAT THE CLERICAL CRYPTO GRANTS
ARE ENGAGED IN TO CHANGE THEIR
BEHAVIOR IN SUCH A FUNDAMENTAL
WAY AND WE CAN BE SAFE ALL
ACROSS THE WORLD UNCERTAINLY AND
IRAQ AND THE MIDDLE EAST.
>> THE HEAD OF THE IRG C, HE HAS
BY ALL ACCOUNTS A BAD CHARACTER
AND HAS LED ALL KINDS OF
ATTACKS.
ARE YOU SAYING THAT HE NOW IS
EQUATED TO LET'S SAY THE HEAD OF
ISIS.
IN U.S. POLICY PERSPECTIVE?
>> YEAH, HE IS A TERRORIST.
>> Bret: IS A COUNTRY WE HAVE
A POLICY TO TARGET HIM OR
CAPTURE HIM?
>> HE HAS THE BLOOD OF AMERICANS
ON HIS HANDS.
AS DOES THE FORCE THAT HE
LEAVES.
AMERICA IS DETERMINED EACH TIME
WE FIND AN ARGUMENT, AN
INDIVIDUAL THAT IS TAKING THE
LIVES OF AMERICANS KUDOS
RESPONSIBILITY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
STUDIO AND WE HAVE MADE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S FIRST FEW YEARS
TO REDUCE THE RISK THAT ANY
AMERICAN BE KILLED EVER AGAIN.
>> CRITICS INCLUDING THE
IRANIANS SAY THIS MOVE HAD MORE
TO DO WITH THE ISRAELI ELECTION
TOMORROW THAT I DID WITH U.S.
POLICY.
YOUR RESPONSE?
>> WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
A LONG TIME AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS A LONG TIME.
IT TOOK A LOT OF WORK TO MAKE
SURE WE HAD ALL THE FACTS RIGHT
AND WE HAD EVERYBODY
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT HAVE
THE RIGHT PLACE WE COULD
ANNOUNCE THIS.
IT HAPPENED TODAY BECAUSE THAT
WAS THE DAY WE ARE READY TO MAKE
THE ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> Bret: I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
LIBYA QUICKLY.
ANOTHER MOVED BY THE GENERAL
LAUNCHING AND OFFENSIVE ON
TRIPOLI, YOUR SENSE OF THE
SITUATION IN LIBYA AND COULD
THERE BE SANCTIONS HEADING THAT
WAY?
>> WE HAVE WATCHED MOVEMENTS,
MALICIOUS AROUND TRIPOLI AND
INTO THE SOUTHERN PART OF
TRIPOLI.
WE HAVE URGED ALL THE PARTIES TO
SOLVE THIS AND SOLVE OUR
DISPUTES.
WE THINK THAT IS THE ONLY WAY
THIS CAN BE RESOLVED, THIS WILL
BE RESOLVED THROUGH A FORCE OF
ARMS, NO WAY THAT WILL TAKE
PLACE.
THERE IS A U.N. PROCESS AND WE
HAVE BEEN A PART OF THAT.
THE GENERAL HAS BEEN A PART OF
THAT AND WE URGED THEM TO STAND
DOWN AND MOVE BACK TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE SO THAT WE CAN
GET A POLITICAL RESOLUTION.
YOU KNOW THE HISTORY OF LIBYA.
THE FRACTURED NATURE OF THE
PLACE AND THE ABSENT POLITICAL
RESOLUTION.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HELP
FIGHTING AND CHAOS.
IT IS NOT IN AMERICA'S BEST
INTEREST AND SO WE ARE URGING
ALL THE PARTIES TO ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATION SO WE CAN GET A
POLITICAL RESOLUTION.
>> Bret: I WANT TO RETURN TO
VENEZUELA, WILL THERE BE MORE
EFFORTS AGAINST THE CUBAN
GOVERNMENT FOR SUPPORTING THE
VENEZUELAN NICOLAS MADURO
REGIME?
THEY SEEM TO BE NOT BUDGING
DESPITE ACTIONS FROM THE U.S.
AND AROUND THE WORLD.
>> IT IS THE CUBANS THAT ARE
PROVIDING THE SECURITY.
THAT HAS TO HAS TO BE
EMBARRASSING IF YOU ARE A
VENEZUELA GENERAL.
A PART FROM THAT, THE CUBANS
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT HE IS A
LOST CAUSE, IT IS NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
HIS DAYS ARE NUMBERED AND THE
NEED TO GET ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
HISTORY.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO ALL WE
CAN TO ENCOURAGE THE CUBANS TO
TAKE ON BOARD THAT
UNDERSTANDING, STOP SUPPORTING
HIM AND ALLOW THE VENEZUELAN
PEOPLE TO HAVE THE DEMOCRACY
THAT THEY DESERVE.
>> Bret: WE HEARD FROM THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION THAT HIS
DAYS WERE NUMBERED BUT WE DIDN'T
KNOW THE NUMBER.
HE IS STILL THERE.
WE ARE HEARING THAT VENEZUELANS
NOT RECOGNIZED LEADERSHIP DAYS
ARE NUMBERED TOO, WHAT DO YOU
PUT THE NUMBER AT?
>> I DON'T HAVE THE NUMBER.
WE KNOW THAT THE VENEZUELAN
PEOPLE WILL ULTIMATELY DEMAND --
THESE SITUATIONS ARE DIFFERENT.
HE CONTROLS A SMALL FRACTION OF
SYRIA TODAY, HE WORKED AT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE TO
DENY HIM THE CAPACITY TO REBUILD
HIS NATION, THE GUY WHO BELIEVES
HE WON WITH THE TRUTH IS THE
MIDDLE EAST IS IN A MUCH MORE
STABLE AND MUCH BETTER PLACE
TODAY THAN IT WAS WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS RUNNING THE
JOINT.
HE LEFT THE SYRIAN PEOPLE IN A
BAD PLACE.
MILLIONS OF DISPLACED PERSONS
UNDER EFFORT TO TAKE DOWN THE
CALIPHATE AND TOO GREAT AN
OPPORTUNITY AND A PROCESS AND
THEY ARE YIELDING REAL RESULTS.
>> Bret: BACK TO CUBA FOR A
SECOND.
IT IS THE MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL
MOVE MORE EFFORT TO PINCH THEM?
>> YEP.
SPEED WENT OKAY, CUT AND DRY.
YES, IT IS.
>> IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO GET
THAT PART RIGHT.
THE CUBANS ARE THE FOLKS WHO ARE
PROVIDING THE SUPPORT, ALONG
WITH THE RUSSIANS AND VENEZUELA.
WE WILL DO EVERYTHING TO PULL
THEM APART SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
HAVE WHAT THEY DESERVE.
>> Bret: TWO NORTH QUICK
THINGS.
SINCE THE WEEKEND, THE HOMELAND
SECRETARY HAS RESIGNED, KIRSTJEN
NIELSEN.
PARA BEN MOORE CABINET SHAKE-UP
MOVES, PEOPLE LEAVING THAT IN
ANY ADMINISTRATION SINCE
WOODROW WILSON.
YOUR SENSE ABOUT THE PEOPLE
MOVING IN AND OUT OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND WHAT THAT
MEANS TO SOMEBODY SITTING AT
HOME?
>> I'M NOT SURE ABOUT YOUR DATA.
I HAVE A CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH
HER, I WISH HER WELL.
THIS MISSION DONE AT THE BORDER
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND YOU
HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE
LAWS RIGHT AND I URGE EVERY
MEMBER TO HELP US SO THAT WE CAN
DO WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
DEMANDING, BECAME SOVEREIGNTY
AROUND OUR BORDER.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK THE
FAMILY SEPARATION POLICY IS
GOING TO CHANGE ALONG THE
BORDER?
>> I WILL LEAVE THAT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
OUR ROLE, THE STATE DEPARTMENT'S
ROLE IS TO WORK WITH ELEMENTS IN
EL SALVADOR, GUATEMALA AND IN
MEXICO SO THEY CAN BETTER SECURE
THEIR BORDERS AND KEEP
INDIVIDUALS FROM MAKING THIS
TRACK UP AND THROUGH MEXICO
WHICH IS VERY DANGEROUS AND
RESULTING IN REAL RISK HERE.
>> Bret: I WOULD BE REMISS IF
I DIDN'T ASK YOU THESE LAST TWO
THINGS.
HAVE YOU ROLLED OUT RUNNING FOR